it's uh been over two years I think
uh since Costello passed away
it still tears me up uh I cried about
him today cried about him today huh it's
it's it's it's proportional to the love
but yeah I'll cry about it right now if
I think but it wasn't putting him down
it wasn't the act of him dying any of
that actually that was a beautiful
experience
um I didn't expect it to be but it was
in my place when I was living in Topanga
during the pandemic where we launched
the podcast and I did it at home
and I he hated the Vets I did at home
and it was he gave out this huge
right at the end and I could just tell
he had been in just not a lot of pain
fortunately but he had just been working
so hard just to move at all and the
craziest thing happened like it was
unbelief I've never had an experience
like this I expected my heart to break
and I felt a broken heart before I felt
it frankly when my parents split I felt
it when Harry shot himself I felt it
when Barbara died and felt it when you
know when Ben went
um so as well and so many friends like
way too many friends I mean the end of
2017 my friend Aaron King
John Johnny Farrer John eichelberry
stomach cancer suicide fentanyl it's
like whoa all in a freaking week and I
just remember thinking like what the but
when cust like and it's just
heartbreaking you just carry that and
it's like uh but and that's just a short
list you know and I don't say that for
SOB stories just for a guy that wasn't
in the military or didn't grow up in the
inner city like it's an unusual number
of like deaths like close people
um
when Costello went the craziest thing
happened my heart warmed up it like
heated up and I wasn't on MDMA and I
wasn't I I was just it just the moment
he went he just went whoosh
and I was like what the hell is this and
it was just it was like a supernatural
experience to me I just never had that
I'd put my grandfather on the ground I
was a pallbearer at the funeral I've
like done that more times than I'd like
to
to have ever done it and
you just heat it up with costume I
thought what the is this and it was
almost like and you can make up these we
make up these stories about what it is
but it was almost like he was like all
right I have to be careful because I
will cry here
um and I don't want to
um
it was almost like he was like
all that effort because I've been
putting so much effort into him it was
like all right you get that back it was
like the giant freaking thank you and it
was it was incredible you know and I'm
not embarrassed to shed a tear or two
about it if I have to like I was like
holy like that's how close I was to
that animal where do you think where do
you think you can find that kind of love
again man I don't know I mean when um
excuse me for for welling up but it was
just I mean it's a freaking dog right I
get it but for me it was
um the first real home I ever had
um but when Costello went
it was like we'd have this home in
Topanga we'd set it up and we're like
and he was just so happy there and I
think it just um
I don't know it was it was like this
weird like Victory slash massive loss
like like we didn't 11 years
freaking did everything everything to
make him as comfortable as possible and
he was super loyal beautiful animal but
also just
funny and fun and and I was like I did
it like like you know I gave as much of
myself to this being as a human I felt I
could without making it you know like
you know detract detracting from the
rest of my life and he Lo and so I don't
know
um when I think about Barbara especially
um I well up and I and it's hard for me
but I mean I talked to her before she
died and that was a brutal conversation
saying goodbye to someone
especially with kids and
um that was hard
um I think that really
um flipped a switch in me where I'm like
I I always knew I wanted kids I'd say I
want kids I want a lot of kids that flip
to switching me I was like I want kids I
want my own kids you might be able to
find that kind of love yeah I think
because it was the caretaking it wasn't
about what he gave me all that time and
the more I could take care of him and
see him happy the better I felt it was
crazy and I I'm I don't know so
and I miss them every day every day
every day
you're uh you got a heart that's so full
of love I can't wait uh for you to have
kids uh for you to be a father yeah I
can't wait I'm ready for it when uh you
know uh when when God decides I'm ready
I'll I'll have them
and then I will still beat you to it as
I told you many times before I think you
should
um absolutely have kids I mean look at
the people in our life because because
we're kind of the if you in case you
haven't realized it already like we're
the the younger of the podcasters but
you know like Joe and Peter and
Segura and you know I'm you know and the
rest right there they're the like the
they're like the tribal Elders right and
um and we're you know we're not the the
youngest in the crew but we're we're if
you look at all those guys
they all have kids
they all adore their kids and their kids
bring tremendous meaning to their life
like we we'd be morons if
you know if you didn't go off and start
a family I didn't start off yeah to
start a family
um and yeah I think that's that's the
goal I mean I think the kids of the
goals that's one of them the kids not
only make them uh their life more joyful
and brings love to their life it's also
makes them more productive makes them
better people all that it's like oh it's
it's it's uh it's kind of obvious yeah I
think that's what Costello wanted I
think I have this story in my head that
he was just like okay like take this I
can yeah and don't forget
Lord knows don't this up Andrew I
love you brother this is incredible love
you too thank you I appreciate you uh
let's as we will talk often on each
other's podcast for many years to come
yes many many years to come thank you
thanks for for having me on here and um
there are no words for how much I
appreciate your example and your
friendship so love you brother love you
too